candles and ribbons commemorate
Germanwings flight 9525 the airline is a
Lufthansa subsidiary Lufthansa's CEO
made one of the hardest announcements of
his career Dunson I've time lobby in our
worst nightmares we could not have
imagined such a tragedy striking our
company Hyman cotton Lufthansa has
always stood for safety and
dependability how will its reputation be
affected long-term Gerhardt fissile used
to work in Lufthansa strategy Department
now he serves the airline as a
consultant and aviation expert how has
it been the past few days of indeed
being very hectic Lufthansa and its
subsidiary have been increasingly
fielding criticism and questions about
their safety standards the disc was
shown on your phone these discussions
have gotten started unfortunately in
some ways and they won't stop anytime
soon target us get him towards each edge
the questions range from the age of the
aircraft to the safety standards and the
pilots training and further development
board has a modest these discussions are
underway and nobody will be able to stop
them that easily topple contact at
present everything seems to indicate
that the copilot intentionally caused
the crash there has been speculation
that he suffered a psychological
disorder that he hid from his employers
dnaliens those in the industry who are
familiar with us know that we select our
cockpit crew members very carefully yeah
we do so because that's part of who we
are that's part of our DNA it's what we
had love khansa believe it in selecting
our candidates we not only examine their
cognitive and technical abilities the
selection process gives a high priority
to the candidates psychological fitness
as well galusha icon deckhand edad no
matter what happens confidence in
Lufthansa has been shaken as rüdiger
Straub points out
he runs an agency that advises aviation
industry companies the market is
absolute / shady the name is definitely
suffered and it's damaged for the long
term that's just fits it it'll take a
very long time for it to return to
anything like normal see it in cases
like this PR experts look at the
professionalism of the crisis
communication how does the company
communicate with the public Straub
praises the response of Lufthansa and
Germanwings especially the black and
grey logo the spies what I'm victory
swords or traditional unclear the fact
that they changed the logo after such a
tragedy was a good move that I'm hoping
your ban chka daughters or sons love to
answer and Germanwings had to
communicate in real-time with the shaft
supervision the plane went down and the
very next moment they had at least a
thousand reporters wanting information
and more sigh community and a fluke
chokers for ungrouped on Aneesa
knoblauch who from Medecins Tolls
enchiladas none on voiding the consumers
also communicate her social media so
given the situation a functioning crisis
manual isn't dispensable annual on up
ding bar
the employees are united in grief with
the CEO just days before the crash they
were at loggerheads over planned reforms
their kind of snow shuffle they can only
do it if the entire workforce both on
the ground and in the air stand behind
him and understand why he's doing these
reforms and what he's planning for the
future and if you can utilize this
momentum I think it'll be easier for him
is everybody at left hands up pulling
together or has the crash driven a
deeper wedge between employees and
management the future of Europe's
largest airline hangs in the balance